j'aime le bruit et la fureur je crois
qu'en réalité ils ne s'occupent que de
même et c'est la raison pour laquelle
moi j'ai décidé d'y aller et de l'envié
que je pense à rien du tout il n'y a
aucun commencement de preuve qu'on
dresse ici en ce moment certains
responsables ses activités terroristes
m'écoute j'avais dit il faut terroriser
les terroristes bien sûr nous allons
mettre tout en oeuvre pour les retrouver
et pour les chats tir parce qu'on avait
aucun moyen
dans ce cas là il vous reste le verbe
vous en plomb donc tous les moyennes que
la loi nous donne et nous le ferons sans
complexe avis aux amateurs j'ai donné le
feu vert pour l'assaut de la maison dans
laquelle étaient les gens d'actions
directes et cédé à un chantage ça
n'empêchera pas d'autres chantages jour
pas quand même que je reste une cible